good luck to everybody who's playing
another nm in there
from usa you see here's a with the
ratings hidden
when i bring this up you don't get to
see any
any ratings
bare bones
okay starting in two one
let's go zen mode
i got a clock no notation
well does notation show up no not even
the notation
all right
so all i have here are
the squares
okay i guess i'll chop now
okay
how far back do i go
i guess i'll go here
i'm asking for trouble is there some
trick here
okay
this is going to be a problem at some
point right
uh i don't think i want to play that
right now though because my king is
vulnerable as soon as my knight moves so
that's a second step with the bishop
there's some time wasted here by white
hmm
that's a big piece to give up
this unopposed bishop definitely wants
to be on the long diagonal
usually a good
rule to follow
is my opponent now not in a pickle
oh
if here the knight could move
and hit my queen so let's let's just go
on the main diagonal
if you have an unopposed bishop
i think if you put it on the longest
diagonal
here
you're well on your way to being in a
good spot
rarely is that bad
i'm taking with the knight by the way
because this is a a nice post for the
night
and i want to be able to chase that guy
away
and also improve my king just a hair
also let me cut out a move
this one right here
this is the most efficient defender v6
i like my position
let me also negate
a night jump here even though i
maybe maybe that was overkill
and uh
is there gonna be some some stuff
happening
with the sacrifice i think if i went
here there might have been some
irritating stuff
let me go here
i mean the more normal approach is to
immediately contest this only open file
that one
all right let me
let me be careful here
oh i could take here with the knight and
then with the bishop and i'm on this guy
i see only now do i see
let me go here i have to be careful with
this move
way down on the clock
all right that
we're gonna have an opposite color
bishop oh you know what i think rook
takes here might have been a move
so my king has a nice hiding spot let me
go here now in case
this move was
gonna
cut my king off
um i don't want both rooks traded uh one
is okay two is not okay with me
as long as i still have one around i
think i maintain winning chances
and with one rook exchange i think my
king will feel a lot more comfortable
approaching in this manner
they're they're in a think tank it's
tough to break down this position now
it's super stable bishop and this guy's
kind of
kind of tough
in a tough spot okay so
let's see
and i can continually duck
um
let me
let me go here
threatening mate and a couple
okay
let me set up something sneaky
i think they're gonna play here
but i'm looking i'm looking for a mating
net
once again threatening
some stuff
i think
might be
asking for some trouble here
um
let's go here
threatening mate
put pressure on the bishop
and also being a spot for this
this is not working out well what i'm
doing
yeah they're able to to defend
it should be a draw
but i will i will definitely try still
let's see
okay the king has to go back
it's still easy to mess up here
especially considering the time
okay
now let me let me approach it like this
no like this
yeah the time is the
oh that's fancy
but i could go here and then here
yeah if i if i took the bishop i i don't
think i could stop that pawn
who did i play there
who did i play
okay that guy
tar
yeah i guess in the end
because i don't have the ratings on you
don't get to see anything
i don't know
hello
rashan oh rosh
rashan
rosham bobo
southpark fan
yeah i should change that setting
oh maybe i could have just clicked that
real quick to see who i was playing
against
i'll do that
okay uh how to approach this
let's look to build on the dark squares
uh i can play this now
okay
and i'm gonna go here
and then let's get this in
okay
pressure
okay
getting the feeling this is a higher
level player
putting a lot of pressure on my center
i don't think i'm playing this so well
trying to hold down to
the e5 point
probably asking for some serious
problems here probably asking for
problems
while i go for this one this knight's
ready to kill me
this is this is very
don't try this at home type
i got i have to keep i have to negate
the night
or i am
cooked
it may still be cooked
okay
let's go here
uh bishop here is that a move i could
probably take and run away
these guys are under control
well we'll see what happens
um really on thin ice here
held together by a thread
wow
killer man
we have ourselves a killer
um
maybe that's not such a problem though
let me let me take like
this if i take with the knight i'm
i'm in a pin so
i'm holding these two points this is a
second rank knight
but
it seems to be held together okay yeah
now now i think for sure i'm
the better side here i'm up the pawn
i've consolidated
i'm able to castle
uh it's a closed position the knights do
really well here
um
this guy is ideal
for as a blockader of this connected
pass pawn
i'm also placing restriction on this
knight
and i don't think i want to even allow
the bishop here but maybe i can't even
do anything about that
let me begin with this move
um
and we're gonna go here next why did i
make this pawn move
and so i could flush this guy away
if i if i want to
do i want to right now
maybe i don't have to
let's get pushing here
in here
maybe king f's king f7
yeah let me get this guy out of here
probably not a good idea oh i have to be
really careful here
ah
okay let me try this one
yeah i should have played there right
away
uh the knight
is ready to jump
you may still jump
i need like a couple more moves still
before i feel comfortable
okay now at least i could consider
flying away
see the queen side
even on the clock
i'm tempted to check out the rating
my opponent here
you know what the what's the bullet
rating
with us
uh
being down on the clock here
okay
could i get could i just get running
like this
let's go here first controlling the
night
oh this hits really hard
put the king on d6
discovery land
yeah there's no time now
all right they resigned who was i
playing
bowser
let me let me get the uh let me change
my preferences let me put the
player's rating back on
that was a
silly idea
okay let's resume
these are my first two opponents 22
high 22 high 21.
all right where are we at
i am in 15th 240 245 in there 12 is in
first
all right
oh and im is in there too i am
nm is in third
all right
still a lot of time 43 minutes
uh chest pawn 01 thank you for the tier
one resub
oh i was supposed to go back into zen
mode
did i did i do the wrong thing
i i put the wrong setting
off
i just disabled zen when i did that
alright let's take here
eventually i'll figure out these
settings
my knight's pinned
not too concerned about that if there's
additional pressure here
it's easily broken
like this
bishop b4
um
i guess we'll take with the bishop
they're really asking for trouble this
night's ready to move
and be a beast
i think now is that time
and why not move forward
okay
this queen is not a reliable defender
she nearly trapped
has to go here
not good news
press z for zen toggle on off
oh that's a freebie
just the letter z oh okay i
i tried that but with control
okay
there let's do it
all right
this stays in
all right we're getting
a boatload of material
nearly mate
i feel like i shouldn't even be
capturing the rook i guess i guess we
could do that too
okay
opponents offering a draw
is going to look back
and wonder what my reaction is to the
draw for i imagine
all right
chacaroni
all right i don't want the rook
here we got the name
okay
back to tournament
maybe i'll just leave it like this
hello taco nexus
uh gammon thank you for the tier one sub
appreciate it
chess pawn 18 months in a row for you
thank you chess pawn
zen mode
okay e4 e5
oh let's go gambit
give all my pawns away
danish gambit declined
okay
i think immediate pressure was necessary
on that guy
d6 instead of moving with the knight
all right let's start with this one
knight b6 no knight b6
this is a little scary here
a little scary
for black
so some fancy move like this i have a
double
double attack on the queen
i guess i'll back up
it's tactically vulnerable that's a big
decision
okay
i think i want to develop
opposite
opposite sides castling
um
yeah
peace play oh we also i also have this
one now
skewer land and here's a double attacker
should be getting some material yeah
they missed that i was on the queen
big trouble here
knifing in
just want to scare this guy away
get the mate
and b7
yeah if the game continued there's this
this
and then the mate on b8
who was i playing
the pickler
all right
i am in third
red wampus thank you for the prime sub
appreciate your support
oh
i just have to use the hot key
it's easy after each game
taco nexus
thank you as well
the taco
uh let's go for this one
okay
yes there you are the taco has
subscribed thank you taco
all right let's play
uh some some gambit here
benko
benko style
okay
hmm
all right i'll take
and
what's the plan
um
i don't know if i want to immediately
put pressure on the knight i'll go here
first
how about this
or
wasting a lot of time
yeah let's go here
then here
so i got a lot of pressure on d5 this is
i think what i'm
gonna be aiming for
an e6 brake
we'll see how this works out
not sure if this is the most appropriate
way to
play this position
all right i wouldn't mind
getting the dark square bishop okay
maybe
maybe i should have captured with the
bishop so i'm i'm threatening to give
the bishop back and then
ooh
okay i think i need to return
if i played rook a6
there's bishop f1 it's not a stable
square rook on a6
back home my queen goes
i think i'll take once
a piece can't be maintained here because
of the pressure
uh maybe i could win them let's see how
the recapture okay the unmasking the
bishop
gotcha
okay
let's go here
knight b5 is maybe a move
but then there isn't direct pressure on
my knight
i think i might want to play here
given the chance start to coordinate
pretty well in the dark squares
oh we got a fork
yeah they missed that one
who is they
i don't think there's any fancy
in-betweeners i could take the rook
and
let me just go here
instead of bishop takes pawn i think the
knight wants to be there yeah i'm not
only threatening to win the pawn but
land a fork
spells double trouble for white
yeah let's take
[Music]
we go with this one i'm okay with giving
back
two miners
for a rook
um
i'll take here straight away let me land
this check
and then go here
you're in a bit of a pickle here bishop
c4
multiple pins
no good way out of it as far as i could
tell threatening me one
all right
i guess we'll take with the bishop
knock out the defender
wait a second
check
here there should be some made on the
light squares
or not
i miss my chance
okay i mean it should still be mate
soon
okay
who was that
satang oh they were in first
all right
silver flame
hello
uh immortal one thank you for the prime
sub also corey zappin thank you for the
the raid cory zappin
whoa i should really make a move
all right i think i need to stop with
the zen stuff it's just confusing me
um also i i don't know if i'm such a fan
of not being able to see
uh the stats i want to see where i'm at
uh
all right
okey-dokey
oh i should have maybe just flicked in
this check
sooner
what's my opponent thinking about maybe
they're tuning into the stream
that's an only move
watch out for the stream tactics
okay
let's go
let's go here
take with the b
be a developer
bishop d7 is
usually a move
i'm just viewing this guy as if he's a
big pawn
uh i'll go back
that's also a move but
after this this then
i don't know
i'd rather not give this guy more
options i think is what it's coming down
to so
let's not initiate the capture on d5
aggression
all right
am i going to get killed
let's see do i have the time to maneuver
my knight
could also whoa
very surprised seeing that move
i think i want to build my center a
little bit
uh
now let's play within the structure i
like that i have this
control over e5
i pr i i don't think i want my bishop
here initially i was going to go there
i think it could be
productive
on this diagonal
so am i concerned about these moves not
really so much
um
this knight on f4 should be a real
powerhouse
it should be able to defend against
really anything
now this is this this knight is probably
worth at least a rook
uh
you know
the game could end in one move with this
guy so close to the king
on a stable square
i should be able to get rid of this
knight
i don't think black can afford to move
chop here go there the ending should be
good for me
this is a
kind of overextended let me let me get
rid of this knight
not true i'm not really sure it matters
which rook
i go to see one with
oh i didn't see that that was even a
move
huh
all right i think i need to play on the
other maybe maybe it is a
maybe that was the correct rook to go
with because i i could consider this
this pawn break okay i need to be
careful here
um we don't we don't want to get mated
on h2
i guess we're gonna seal it
and
or
i could consider hunting that pawn
no what am i talking about
all right now let me try this one
if i did this this and then here there's
queen h4
i wanna i'm threatening now to
take and then attack it for a second
time
okay how about we try this
a little fancy maneuver
a little fancy maneuver
i feel like my opponent is playing this
well
what's the plan from here
my id initially was to defend this
anticipating that one but i also have
this
uh let's go here straight away
we got these
these tough guys here
okay i think i should be getting
something
something sweet
okay i could get the
queens off
i'm getting material
time though
clock clock clock
okay oh no i could take with this guy
all right
just enough gas in the tank
all right
got where am i at 20 with fire still 25
minutes to go
nilish
okay let's go for
affine keto
okay
is amish
is going to go for what polgar played
oh it could still kind of turn into that
let me play with this one
and let's see if this one stopped no
all right i'm gonna get this one in
right now
temporary pawn sack
we've got some open lines this is
already
a little concerning here for white
bishop uh queen here
is a move or queen hears even a move or
even knight takes h2 i have a healthy
pick
they that one
that one or this one
what is best
i think what's best is queen h4
immediately
threaten mate
i'll go for that one
yeah let's go for this one
h3 queen takes knight
this guy's under control
this guy's not okay so they're allowing
me to take that
all right i don't want to take with the
queen i'm gonna take with the knight
there's nothing wrong with taking with
the queen i don't think
maybe get in another developing oh no
how about that one
yeah try and scare away a rook
okay
see right here i don't know if i even
want to take that rook
let me take here now why
it's giving white some squares
um
yeah let me let me let me just get rid
of that
i didn't even see that that was a move
um
i missed something good i'm pretty sure
to only be up a pawn right now
it shouldn't be
i wonder why why wasn't i considering f5
a little earlier
let's maybe let's go with f5 now
let's go like this
then here
almost mate
this knight is
oh i just resigned okay
almost 400 in here
um
what am i missing here
corey zapping
oh okay i got that one thanks again for
the raid bubsky thank you for the prime
resub six months now
thank you bubsky
feels like a three points rook
okay
oh this was the one with the knight went
there okay let's maybe try an e4 game
let me try maybe we could try smith
moore there we go we have a sicilian
oh that's
that's different
um
i haven't seen this one before
okay
my idea is to
go here
do i even bother
regaining the pawn with that knight
let's
let's hit hit once
let's go here
let's go here
i don't know
i held off on this move because i
thought e5 might hit
and i'd prefer to not have that move get
in there so easily
now maybe instead of castles i should
have played a3b4
all right i'm going to get this one in
i have two defenders of this
so i can't be scared away too easily
though
my opponent is trying
could move forward
i am covering c8
they're not giving me a kick so let's
coordinate with this guy i'm on a7
back off here
okay
i'd like to have some stability let me
get the flight square in
also stop knight g4
this is still uh kind of irritating
okay let me try and control the night
ugh
yeah night there is a good move
i don't think i have anything
knight c7 there
okay what's that tricky night up to
all right let's get out of the check
so easy to miss something
yeah maybe i want my bishop on c3
it's ready to play here straight away
ah feels even
oh nice move okay
yeah there's some tricks if i went here
and let's keep the rooks defended
to watch out for brook takes c4
put some ponds on dark i guess
um
what to do what to do what to do
i don't know
it's tricky okay let's go back maybe i
could win this pun
i
missed that move
okay
am i just barely tracking that pond down
or not
oh
could just take that pawn
am i doing
i'm in a pickle and i can't get out of
it
is that even necessary
okay oh
threefold
oh man i'm lucky i didn't lose that one
uh deflect thank you for the prime sub
uh
nick sapphire thank you for the tier one
sub and serenity no i love that name
yes we got a seinfeld fan here
love it serenity now
george costanza's
father
okay
serenity now
all right oh the exchange
right what's the move here
this one
and
i have to take
and then the idea here is what challenge
this guy
there's also
the capture
i think
here and then this straight away
i think
the plan is this one and then here
the old double attack
challenge this strong bishop
try and maintain it
pawn falls
i'm back five
not going to be many very many games
remaining
all right i think the plan
has to it has to it has to start with
that got to get rid of that bishop
and
i think
playing with this pawn is the way to
soften up this structure maybe get a
hole on b3
be disruptive
i play b5 b4
in b3
yeah i'm not sure
i should be moving a rook here um
i think
they should stay put and i
move some pawns
maybe i should be in a spot to maybe
question the night
oh i didn't see that one
all right
i'm going to be losing some material
soon
there should be a tactic here
is there
maybe
not let's go here
bishop d4
maybe
then rook here
covering a lot of ground
these guys are
super
active
and they still have to worry about
potential back rank matrix
i have a flight square opponent is not
this guy is not around as a defender
only one defender
there's pins in this diagonal there's
there's problems
for my opponent to solve
all right that one
yay maybe i give the knight a shove
yeah let's give the knight a shove
and then take on e4
i'll be hitting the bishop
i mean i i guess i could have captured
first and then played here
but
doing it like this so now there's this
double attack
rook here the only move oh i didn't oh
that's not a move though
i could take the piece and defend my my
bishop
okay
take this guy keep the healthy structure
and then
track this guy down
that's the plan king will be cozy on g6
go here
go there
i push some pawns
um
let's cut the king up
good play here
forks
go here
so that way when i take here i'm
defending my bishop
if i went here there's this one
all right let's
step one put my bishop on a stable
square
uh i didn't have to play here the king
can't go here it's me
all right we're down on time
we had here uh i'm back 11.
try to get podium is it podium possible
probably not after that draw
it's all it takes one little hiccup
ready
for d5 brisa chest one
uh streicher thank you for the tier one
resub 84 months now for you thank you so
much
fartas
thank you for the prime sub as well
for tas and elk
all right i'm going to go here right now
because i want to be in a position
to meet b3
with b5
and i want to have my queen defending
the rook
okay
i think
going for this capture is fine
uh maybe i should play this right now
you know let's do it
because there was this idea
to clamp down
so now this is maintained
um i think i need to castle
let me step up here i don't like that
i'm in some pin
but
i think it should be all right
queen there
let me start with this one
that way that way if e4 is in there it's
not hitting with
tempo and now
now that my bishop is on d3 i think now
i
drop in here
and i'll
basically have a super aggressive bishop
um
i just uh
now i
simply cannot rely upon my bishop to
defend any light squares on my side of
the board i i have gone all in
with this guy
so i'm looking to somehow work some
magic
if i can
with my light square bishop i think i
need to begin
by getting rid of their dark square
bishop
and then
i think this this is what i'm gunning
for this this pawn right here uh this
pawn right here
rook b8 or queen to b8
oh that's running into this one
knight takes pawn
oh
this
and this knight might end up stuck
uh i will get to the second rank
okay let's get here now another the
knight and the rook cannot play
really
um
yeah i think this is working out for me
or is it
or is it
i guess i could
let me start with this one
trying to be a little clever here if i
play this here and then that
okay now i'm
now
kind of upset that i didn't play that
right away
yeah i should have put my rook here and
after the night move then went here
okay
queen a2 is what i want
i think i can control the knight
okay that one
let's go here
first
let's try this again
queen trade i'm just down so much time
okay now we get this one in
queen f5 after knight f1
i think this is collapsing you have to
play here
this rook is not in position to
get rid of these guys so i should be
slithering on in there
start with the check
go here
there's a check if the knight moves
also we have this
queen g3 queen corner pocket
i think it's mate no matter what
next
move can't be stopped
i think there was some fancy stuff too
it wasn't me king g1
night promotion and i got 30.
yeah
podium land is not happening
kappa
kappa thank you for the prime sub
appreciate it kappa
salomon
final opponent for this tournament
french
i don't think this one is going to count
king's indian attack
is what we have oh that might be a
little too early
a commitment
i think this is
this is normally the idea
i think black is looking to
play here
so i'm gonna interfere with that idea
now i'm in a spot to meet that with that
okay
this is the other approach
pressure on e5 i want to maintain
control over this square
so much for that though the knight could
return
all right
uh let's begin with this one
this knight does not want to be here
well he wants to be on e5
as soon as possible
okay you're threatening f2
let me support the queen
well the ma the main thing is to stop
queen takes f2
knight on a4 is no big deal
uh let's put more pressure here this
stops knight d7 let's let's continue to
keep pressure
at this point this this stops uh black
from
improving the night
do i have a trick
knight here and then here
um
okay i'm gonna withdraw this rook
because i'm somewhat concerned about
knight a4 if i played here right away
knight a4 was annoying
let's go with this
i'm looking at these two moves now g4 e5
if this i could exchange bishops and
take on d5 so they're cutting that one
out but i should still try somehow or
another to maneuver to e5 so now that
this one's in this is a weakened square
a knight on f3 should be a powerhouse
okay they have a diagonal i didn't want
to see the night get there
bishop here okay let's get this one in
and this i i think i'm in a spot already
where i could sacrifice an exchange
a knight ending ending up here other no
i could take the knight
let me start with this one though
i have
everything hitting e6 however indirect i
think i'm winning upon
take here first
and i might as well take the pawn
i was tempted to play it but more
positionally not even give up my strong
knight for the bishop
but upon his opponents upon
determined is long over
and what is the clear path forward
let's keep some defense of this in case
of that
base point i could cover
three to two majority on the king side i
want to get it rolling
oh this is another reason to have the
rook here i could play this
maybe a little faster
let's go with this one i like to keep my
king stopping the entry points
this one a little air
so i
want more open files i want another
target that's the better way to say it
so
i guess i'll take here
and now
force that rook on the defensive and
only after the rook
is in this defensive state
i'm going to improve the king
so i could go hunting for this but then
these two are going to fall the king is
cut off
must stay in the
the king's quadrant
let's keep the king cut
all right now flush it back
and now we
get back to improving the king
just a hair or maybe not
let's get the pawns rolling some
i should get behind this passer before
it's maybe too late
i'll pick off this pawn
running mate
no stalemates to worry about
all right
that is going to do it
final standings i took sixth
459 in there who took first flawless
this guy right here
j the jolly one
mono and then chest by jason
art vega
david vova
all right
there's your
your top page let me throw a good games
all
all right fun as usual
an hour of 3-0
very nice
you